- I feel like.
(crowd cheering)
Give it up. Keep going.
Alright, alright, alright.
Have you met DJ Cassidy before?
I wanted to ask you?
He's up with us
- I think I have.
- He's up there. But keep looking for him.
- What up?
- [Chance The Rapper] Oh, what up man?
- What up? How are you?
- I'm good. Good to see you.
- [DJ Cassidy] Good to see you.
We've met at the White House a few times.
- [Chance The Rapper] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I was gonna say, I think I was actually
there the one time cause that's what we
- [Chance The Rapper] Yeah,
I saw, I saw you there too.
- We were all there guys.
- At the White House.
- [DJ Cassidy] Epic nights.
- It's great to have you at, The Voice,
but do you think you're gonna win?
- Do I think I'm gonna win the voice?
I'm pretty sure I'm gonna win.
- [Kelly Clarkson] You're pretty sure?
- Yeah. - [Kelly] Okay.
- You know I'm gonna win the voice.
- [Kelly Clarkson] You
have a really good team.
- Yeah. My team is fire.
- I don't know, I might win, I don't know.
- Your team is good.
- I'm, I don't know.
I feel like it's a different show.
I've done another competition.
I know you have too.
- [Chance] Mhm
- [Kelly] Rhythm and flow, right?
- Yeah. Rhythm and flow.
- Yeah. So I've done something else too.
This one's different for me. Is the voice,
Is it what you expected?
- It's a, it's a lot different
than I thought it was gonna be.
It's a lot. It's a lot of fun.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- We have a lot of fun.
- Yeah. I think-
- [Kelly Clarkson] You're funny.
- [Chance] We are,
- [Kelly Clarkson] You are,
I have cried and had to have
makeup redone, kind of funny.
- Yeah. I think that's my
favorite part about it.
It's like a very easy environment.
Like you, and Blake,
and Nile are all cool.
Everybody that works on the show is cool,
and there's a lot,
it's a lot more hands-on
than I thought it was gonna be.
Like a lot of like, you know,
like I do like production work
and stuff. - [Kelly] Yeah.
- For Peter Cottontail and
so like, getting the work
on the arrangements of
the songs and on like
the vocal production part.
I have a, can I say what's
going on in this show yet?
- I don't know if you
can say, but you do have-
- She knows, way better than I can
- No, no. I dunno what you can say,
but I will say that's been
my favorite part watching you because I,
I don't know if I've
ever really done it with
a full on producer before.
Like, you know what I'm saying?
You're a rapper, you're
singer and a producer.
And it, it was interesting
to do the blinds with you.
- [Chance] Yeah.
- Cause I was threatened.
Cause I was, cause I
was like, oh wait, what?
I can't do that. Like what
he just did like it, it was cool.
You were like producing
like during the blinds, like
to, that was part of your pitch.
- [Chance] Yeah.
- Which kind of which. I didn't like.
- You didn't like?
- No, I liked it for you.
I didn't like it for me.
- You got everybody that
I, there was a bunch
of times where we turned, right?
- [Kelly] Okay.
- And you were like there
- [Kelly] There were a
bunch of times you got it.
- [Chance] There were, maybe, 2 times
- No. - [Chance] But most of the people,
Kelly, what?
- Lies? Lies and deception.
- They would give a whole speech
about how they love me
and oh coloring book
And they're like, but Kelly
Clarkson and they'd go to you.
(laughing)
- I feel like that happened with Niall.
I think it's-
- [Chance] Niall did get
- They'd pick Niall. -
[Kelly] Nile got a few skills
- I know, I can't, yeah,
I can't compete with that.
So do you remember the
first time that you fell
in love with hip hop? Was
it when you were like a kid?
- Ooh, that's a good question.
It is the 50th anniversary.
- It is I know. 50 years.
- What a great question.
(audience cheering and clapping)
- That's a monumental thing also.
It's been the voice of
liberation for so many people
and like brought so many
people together for years.
The first time I remember falling
in love with hip hop being honest, was,
I was in fourth grade
and I went to a pizza
restaurant with my parents.
I had a Walkman CD player.
- Oh. I had that, anti-skip.
- With anti-skip with a FM radio on.
- Yeah. You were so cool.
- Right? Yeah. No, I was
in money or no, but I
(kelly laughing)
but I had this, I had the
FM radio on and I was listening
to Power 92 in Chicago.
Number one in the streets.
Shout out to Power 92.
And they,
and the DJ says something like, "man
we got this young cat. He's outta Chicago.
You know him as a producer,
but he is about to drop a album."
And they played the song called,
"Through the Wire," by Kanye West.
- Oh with Chaka.
- And yeah with Chaka Khan.
And it had the high pitch soul sample
and you could hear him like,
it was just like a, it was a
it was a life-changer moment for me.
I just remember being
like, "I understand this.
The speaks to me. I'm
young, but I get it."
And I feel the,
the attitude and the energy behind it.
Yeah, that was like, I feel like a
a big reason why I got into making music.
- That's cool.
- [Chance] Yeah. - I
didn't know that story.
- Yeah.
Also, I hate to break the
fourth wall, but like,
there's like, there's
people in these photographs
- Yes.
- That are moving. -
[Kelly] No, no, they're not-
- Like Harry Potter.
(Kelly laughs)
- What up y'all?
- [Kelly Clarkson] Like Harry Potter?
(kelly laughing)
You can actually, you just pick which one
and then it opens and
then you go to that room.
No I'm just kidding. -
[Chance] That's what like I
was saying like, are these portals?
- No, this used to be, these are portals
to wherever they are at now we have it.
Our whole audience used to be screens.
- [Chance] Oh really?
- And then it was kind of cool
cause we got to have people
from all over, not only the
states but the world at times.
So it was cool to keep.
So we kept some of them.
We thought it was cool. Yeah.
- Yeah.
- So you're like you're going live
like all across everywhere.
We don't even know where right now.
- No. I'm way less scared now.
(kelly laughing)
- So, wait, you ran
into somebody recently?
Cause I remember sitting next
to you at the voice and you were like-
(both laugh)
- I ran into Owen Wilson, yeah.
you ran into Owen Wilson, and I love it-
- Owen Wilson, ladies and
gentlemen, Owen Wilson.
(audience applauding)
Yeah.
- [Kelly] So I have to
ask though, first of all
this is what I really wanna ask.
Keep this photo up. Who is this guy?
- [Chance] Who, who is this guy right?
- [Kelly] No but, he seems
angry at you specifically.
- Look, let me tell the story.
So you know I'm in the visual art space
right now.
So I go to a lot of like arts fairs,
like stuffy events and stuff.
And so, Frieze Los Angeles,
is happening and I went
to like the, the launch party for it.
And I see Owen Wilson,
who I'm a huge fan of
like all the different genres
of Owen Wilson fan, like films.
- Me too.
- I like, I like Drillbit
Taylor, but I also
like all the West Anderson films.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I like Wedding Crashers.
- [Kelly] Of course you do
- I could go on, I could give you
a dissertation right
now on why he's so dope.
Wow. He's fire.
- Night at the Museum.
- Yeah, Night at the Museum.
- I love that one.
- Yes. So then,
(kelly laughs)
so I see, you're hilarious dude.
(audience laughs)
So
- I had to throw it in there
- So I see Owen Wilson at this party.
I'm like, oh my God, this is Owen Wilson.
I go up to him, I'm like, "Hey, I wanna
I want to just give you your flowers
and tell you how dope you
are and you know, meet you."
And he was super nice. He
was like, "I love your work.
Let's take a picture." I'm
like, "Let's take a picture."
He was like, "But let's do it like,
we're talking to each other
like we're in conversation."
I'm like, "Bet."
My homie Reese is right next to us.
He just starts flicking us up.
And the first flick,
you see enemy number one
this dude right here.
(audience laughing)
With this spy jacket on
- [Kelly] Spy jacket
is eyeballing me.
But I don't see him yet.
Go to the next photo.
This guy jumped in line
and started talking to Owen Wilson.
- Wait can you see Owen
Wilson's face right now?
- [Chance] Yeah -
[Kelly] He's not into it.
- Wait, here's the crazy thing.
He made it seem, you know,
sometimes you can make it seem
like you know somebody like,
- Oh yeah
- Oh I haven't seen you in so long.
Or they make a joke
and that's what he did.
He just stepped on the conversation.
He goes, oh yeah, blah blah blah blah.
And Owen Wilson's like,
"oh yeah for sure, I guess."
Look at his. He's like, "I guess."
Go to the next photo.
That's me.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
Highly perturbed.
Cause I'm starting to realize,
this guy doesn't know Owen Wilson.
(kelly and audience laughing)
So I tell Owen Wilson,
"Nobody treats you like this."
And I got that guy up outta there.
Go to the next slide.
Yeah. That's me telling
him he is gotta go.
And that lady behind him is saying, "Yeah
it's time to go buddy."
Cause we were Owen Wilson's security.
- Oh man.
He maybe had too much to
drink, got super confident.
- I'm not giving him any excuses.
- [Kelly] Okay. Okay.
- He was probably completely sober.
That's just his
personality. - [Kelly] Okay.
(Kelly laughing)
And then go to the next photo I think,
we have a happy ending.
Happy ending, it's me and Owen Wilson
(audience clapping)
conversing.
- Oh I love it. Oh my God.
I just love, I was like,
"Who's the creeper?"
I was like, "who's in the photo with you?"
- Boo you dude.
- [Kelly Clarkson] I
know. I love you so much.
Okay, I have to ask about new music.
So are you coming out with anything soon?
- [Chance] Yeah. - Okay.
- So,
(Audience cheers)
- [Kelly Clarkson] Exactly.
(audience cheering and applauding)
- Yeah, so my new album's
called, "Star line Gallery."
It's a collaboration
with a lot of different
folks from around the world
telling our stories
- So cool
- in a new kind of way.
And I'm actually performing my new single
"Yah Know," on Jimmy Fallon.
- Oh, that's awesome.
(audience applauding)
Is that the one that you did the video
for that you showed me
when you were on the boat?
- Where I was the,
where I was the captain?
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
Didn't you direct it, as well?
- Yeah. So yeah, I did direct
that video. Thanks Kelly.
- That's so cool.
You're so cool.
- You're a great friend
for saying that on TV.
What up daytime TV.
- I'm not-
- Look at me directing
(kelly laughing)
I just, I would never
be like, I'll direct it.
You did such a good job.
It was so cool.
Reuben and I were talking
about a minute ago.
Anyway, we need another break.
Look out for new music for
Chance the Rapper soon everybody.
And be sure to watch, The Voice, Mondays
and Tuesdays on NBC
where I will be beating Chance the Rapper.